this
we're talking about real things here you
know because the muslims sometimes they
think okay just theoretical virgin
virgin
never saw porn never saw porn village
village come together
okay everything will work out perfectly
it's not like that
even so my clients they reported that
sometimes the man
asks to watch porn with his wife on the
marriage night
subhanallah what kind of thinking is
that you know but this is the kind of
mentality that people bring into the
marriage night
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
if both of them have responsibilities or
roles
it is irrational to expect or demand
that they fulfill something which allah
himself is not made obligatory
this whole thing about uh i still want
him to do a little bit of
dishes or just do a little bit of the
choice
if he does it he does it if he doesn't
he doesn't but you cannot
expect that similarly if a woman wants
to work
cool you know women can work i'm not
against that she wants to go to school
cool
but you cannot expect her to make money
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dhonia of the three muslims
we are joined here with myself fired on
hell
rami who's currently praying also a
little late but he will join us in a few
minutes
and brother gabriel assalamu alaikum
so today is episode 6 of the notorious
infamous infamous i was gonna say in
intimacy
infamous intimacy series episode six so
today we are talking about marriage
night we already talked about
before nikah during the cafe preparing
for it let's go into it
yes alhamdulillah episode six right
mashallah
i mean looking at the comments in the
section of our
podcast i think people are really really
benefiting
so i think we discussed that we're gonna
try to get a bit more specific just
because people are asking
some details and discussions right so
talking about marriage night
um let's go back a little bit we talked
about vetting
and how to choose the spouse what are
the red flags in episode five
we talked about how our communities not
really
ready to give education
to young men and women to know how to
approach this subject which is a very
critical subject
that scholars have discussed before
there is this dilemma in the muslim
community
where discussing intimacy is a big taboo
but it is one of the greatest problems
of our community
and as a counselor now for you know
quite a long time mashallah
uh i've i could say that that is one of
the greatest
problems in marriage
intimacy why well
because it's part of the fitra it's part
of your natural disposition it is one of
the main objectives of
marriage and i think in the 21st century
is just
that intimacy has been
smeared or dirtied by the
you know western approach porn
media pop culture
rap and uh
you know uh yeah kind of like that
culture where women are always
sexualized
and it's become very cheap
so a lot of times when the muslim
community thinks of
intimacy they interpret it in the light
of that
so hence they're like uh it's something
that is like yeah they want it's a
desire but it's like there's this
contradiction an ethical contradiction
in dealing with this like it's like you
cannot have intimacy unless you're like
dirty or something you know
something like that or if even if you're
you're dirty it's something wrong or
i don't know why i was smiling bro i
just wanted to give a quick shout out
salaam alaikum to the king of intimacy
who is back from salah
king of interest so so i think that's
that's a problem that that
we're faced with is intimacies all
around us
it's been made very dirty
and the muslims are like well should i
engage in that is there something i can
talk about is it going to affect my
islam
am i not a good person if i have desires
so some people try to suppress their
desires
which is not something that the prophet
did as long as the halal was there or
the permissible
so within the permissible there was no
suppression of desires except for
in ramadan obviously when you're fasting
as well as maybe if he was making a
tikka
in the last 10 days of ramadan other
than that there was no
suppression of desire within the process
actually it's reported brussels sin
would be very intimate and he would
visit sometimes all his wives in one
night can you imagine that strength
so i know a lot of muslims like oh my
god you know like
are you are you for real like yeah man i
mean this is this is what the process
uh would be in the hadith and the
narrations are
available and many of the scholars have
written about this and that's my dilemma
it's like why
the previous generations that were
supposed to be more conservative than us
in deen and faith and culture
have addressed these issues yet today in
the 21st century it's either
you go the western way and like remove
islam from it or either you go
the muslim way and have like zero or
almost no intimacy or consider intimacy
a burden
or something is gonna take away from
allah and i discussed this in a video
recently that i released called about
being intimate during
in the nights of ramadan or during
ramadan right because a lot of people
are not intimate in ramadan like they
think that it's going to take away from
their worship
we just finished ramadan they think it's
going to take away from their worship
and their connection to allah
and i'm like but the prophet saws didn't
do that and the surah baqarah discusses
this issue that the sahaba some sahaba
couldn't do it like
they just basically would during you
know would break it because
it was not allowed to do that at night
first and then allah eased
the ruling and allowed them to have it
during the night
so these things were discussed so again
my dilemma
that i'm trying to solve and i think we
are trying to solve here with the
three muslim uh three muslims podcast
is to educate our community on
intimacy within islam
you know and and that islam talks about
this and educates
about his why what's the objective of
education
knowledge is saves you from making
mistakes
if you know something you will do it
correctly if you don't know then you
will make mistakes
and mistakes have repercussions so
that is why we are trying to do this so
now
we need communities to watch this
podcast
to research to start coming up with
educational sessions pre-marital
counseling and so on because we are
having a lot of problems
after marriage and you know damage
control
is more expensive and it takes more
resources than preemptive measures
so we need to educate divorce rates in
the community now
are over 50 from what i've seen some
statistics
so it is a huge problem
all right so let's say you do get your
theory and you get some knowledge of
intimacy you watch our you know the
three muslims podcast
and you get you know to episode six and
you finish episode six
and then you know you're getting married
next week right
so at least you can have some knowledge
of what to do and what not to do if you
don't watch these episodes and these
years
well what are the problems or the
mistakes that you gonna make
all right so what happens for those who
are not knowledgeable some of the common
problems and mistakes of the marriage
night and as you know it is a sunnah of
the prophet saw
to consummate the marriage
to consummate the marriage on the
marriage night on the day
of the nikah once you've done the care
that night is basically a sunnah
to consummate and the next day is a
sunnah to have walima a walima is just
like a small
feast or or a table spread and the
prophet sallam
in some instances i think when he
married
safiyah
that he just had some dates and some
honey and some you know small things
that he made the walima with next day
after consummating the marriage
what's the point of consummating
marriage see intimacy is
it brings two people together it's the
greatest
physical spiritual emotional
connection it is what brings you a
marriage means
two people now are becoming into one
family
i mean connecting on all levels
including the physical connection right
you're literally connected
and that is symbolical whatever you want
to take it but it's so
important because it's like the first
expression of love that you can have
and if you have built some psychological
blocks
around this then of course
you're not going to be able to connect
hence it's going to take you some time
to basically uh you know have
this unity amongst you and to have a
healthy relationship that's why a lot of
brothers and sisters don't consummate
the marriage
because of the blocks the mental
psychological blocks that they've built
around
intimacy to basically
delay the consummation and
or make mistakes on the consummation
night
and then cause problems for the rest of
the relationship or going forward
so knowledge is is very very important
preemptive education
teaching them what does it mean what is
sex what is intimacy what will happen
and if people don't even know their
biology how do you
it's like what are you gonna do you know
i remember one one brother he called me
like he just
you know he just uh he got married and
he called me the next
it was actually like a few weeks after
his marriage
and he said how do i know
that i've actually penetrated
and i was like ah
okay so i had to explain the to be a big
graphic on explaining the
the biology of it but the brother didn't
know if he had actually
done intercourse or not if he's
penetrated or not
so that's that's to the amount that it
goes right the
the people are they don't know sometimes
or
sometimes they know too much because
they've watched you know pornography and
all that
and um there can be a lot of trauma
that's caused
because of that so
let's go back so you have your wedding
mashallah everyone comes they wish you
you know
happy life bring you the gifts
everyone's excited right the girls
probably terrified
because she's very you know uh very like
shy or whatever
especially if it's a virgin woman if
it's not a virgin woman and people need
to understand sometimes when it's talked
about marriage
they only focus on virginity
they don't understand that marriage
happens sometimes for some people two
three four times
in a lifetime and if a woman is not a
virgin anymore then it's a whole
different dynamics
a whole different thing but in general
if it's a virgin
obviously she's going to be quite uh
quite shy
maybe quite depending again what culture
and who she is that also changes it's
not
black and white like that but in general
she's going to be nervous
and maybe the guy is going to be very
nervous
so there's yeah there's a variety of
different situations that can happen
here but let's say we talk about
inexperienced clear clean
brother and sister getting together
who've never really been exposed to
pornography or
know very little about intimacy and then
they basically get together they haven't
been taught anything
they've just heard things and now you
know they finish the marriage
the family kind of walks them to their
hotel room right it's like a practice
that happens in muslim communities right
they get to the hotel room you know
everyone's screaming loud whatever you
find this amongst different
cultures and uh you know and then
basically door is closed
they're left alone right so now they're
looking at each other they're like
so what should we do you know so the guy
most likely will pull a move on
okay and he'll try to do something and i
don't know
uh he might make a mistake it might
scare the girl off
and for the remainder of the night
they're gonna one's gonna sleep on the
couch and the other one's gonna sleep on
you know in the bed right and that
happens
while i left because i had to go i had
to go clean something up
um did we give the disclaimer already
that we're gonna go in with the terms
not okay no let's give a disclaimer all
right so if there's any
kids watching um insha allah
if you wanna you know ask some parental
uh
consent if you wanna stay for this if
not bro
just i would not be here but if you're
if you're trying to learn how the
the way the world works and you want to
really you know get woke then
by all means bismuth okay
good disclaimer all right so
yeah so sometimes these guys will sleep
tonight one on the couch one on the bed
right so they have they will not be
touching each other
and it's going to take to some people it
took even super so my clients they said
years to actually have intimacy years
there was one of my friends who had a
client
i think it was 80 years they were not
intimate since they were married
eight this one was this one shocked me
and i think those other problems in
there
are linked to that but 80 years
to not be touched and i think my first
question was to my colleague was why did
you
like to ask them like why did you wait
so long you know to get help right
so shyness
anxiousness all these things can play a
part
and subhanallah if we look at so this is
the problem let's look at the correct
way the sun of the prophet sallam was
that
as some of the scholars said that for
example you would pray with your wife
right so you kind of break the you know
you break the uh
the ice you know so you pray together
and write some nawaf
and one of the sheikh said you know he
said he got married
and he said i started praying right and
you know he was next to his wife
and he said i start reciting surah
baqarah
you know 286 verses right and he said i
saw my wife getting nervous you know and
i just
he said i was just playing with her i
just wanted to go more and more recite
more
and i just saw her getting more and more
nervous you know and then i you know
then i ended it right and i looked at
her i was like i was just playing with
you right
and they were both laughing right but
that was like a way to like break the
ice you know
and and one of the soonest the processor
is also to like give something sweet to
your wife like from your hand
right like something like sweet
something nice you know just feed her
something
just talk and just like kind of flirt
you know
and that's what a lot of men don't
understand you are the kawam you are the
one who's gonna make the
first move now there might be as i said
a woman who is more outgoing maybe from
a different culture
like i remember one of the brothers
married a brazilian sister you know and
he wanted to divorce her
and this is one of the you know part of
the uh
the counseling uh that was going by
someone else but
and we asked him like why do you want a
divorce and he's like she's just like
too you know i'll go you know he's like
i feel like my god you know this is not
correct you know
so you know one of the i know and one of
the brothers after he left he says like
it's okay if he divorces like i'll just
find her and you know like that's my
dream
[Laughter]
he's like come on man like brazilian
outgoing like that and
she just wanted the brother you know
she's like we asked him like is there
something wrong is she not covering
properly
is she like being bad outside he's like
no no no but she said when it comes to
intimacy
she's just like you know out there like
she starts things you know
and now and the brother was like okay no
problem
it's like you know it's okay like just
let me know and i'll take care of it
right it's funny but that's the reality
and i was like bro like what's wrong
with you man like that's a dream for a
lot of men you know
like just you know you know what i was
gonna do
bro not gonna lie like that's how most
men are today with women once you know
the nikah is done they don't know
anything about you know like you said
about foreplay and all that they just go
they just want to go right in and you
know that's not really how reality works
for men
it's very easy because our our signals
to you know arouse us our arousal you
know
so what i'm looking for triggers are
different than women
all right yeah we get very little
hashtag foreplay starts in her mind
that's right that's right a woman's
orgasm starts in the mind
a man's orgasm starts in his eyes
all right that's where it starts what he
sees is he's you know he's triggered he
starts getting you know turned on
so he needs to pace himself he's kawan
he is the one who basically makes the
first moves
and he needs to take it easy so the
prophet salallahu he advised the sahaba
he said send messengers so the sahaba
sometimes would not understand what the
prophesy says so they would ask
you know ya rasulullah what does
messengers mean he said words and kisses
so some of the scholars have explained
this they said don't jump onto your wife
don't rush
okay because she's different uh before i
got married the first you know
time my sheikh said he said a great
analogy he said
guys are like uh like microwaves you
know ding ding ding ding
right you get turned on fast you know
heat it up fast he said women are like
ovens you know you got to put at 240 250
and i go that you know how the sound
makes of the oven right
and then it has to cook and it has to
cook right it takes time for the
the heat to be at the right level you
know what i mean yeah i like
i like i like that too because like when
you get a microwave going
that's it it's done after about like a
oven once you get that heated up
it could it could stay warm for a while
bro it can stay warm for
yeah i like that effects
i know is that a prayer map behind you
yeah it's beautiful right
marshall bro nice it was a gift
i felt beautiful it was a gift
romney bro you've been absolutely uh
uninvolved and
a lot of higher or should i say fake
fake kaya from the uh what did you call
me the king of intimacy
the king the beard looks
good by the way bro it's really good bro
i'm just um i'm just listening in
mashallah i think
you know everything the brother's saying
is is highly important masha allah
and i feel like it would be an injustice
for me to uh to jump in i feel like you
know masha'allah he's on a roll and
i should just let him you know
yeah i have a question should i have a
question
uh it's probably gonna sound real dumb
but
consummating that that's to have sex
right
yeah okay i thought so
yeah consummates have sex intercourse uh
basically penetration and subhanallah
the scholars have discussed even the
details of how that happens you know
what i mean
again contrary to popular opinion these
things are discussed in islam
yeah so going back to foreplay you know
the process of said
kisses and words so kisses obviously
this is something that
i think it's it's it's final i don't
know um
i think kissing is very important just
that connection
of you know the lips and uh you know
just that that touching is something
that really really
turns on both sides and i think
it's been distorted and i think these
days people
stay away from each other again due to
maybe the way sex is portrayed in
popular media it's just about like you
know intercourse
and it's not there's not so much
emotions i think kissing involves a lot
of emotions and passion
and right there's you know growing up
right there's always like the question
are you a good kisser
is because kissing was so important like
15 20 years ago
right and right now it's like all about
just like sorry you know banging
right it's like tak tak talk and there's
no emotions there's no passion
and i think that's just not doesn't work
maybe some people like that and we'll
talk about that you know a bit more
hardcore and whatnot
it was a question that was asked
recently on 50 shades of
of gray right on the issue of bondage
and you know
hardcore right we can talk about that as
well but i think the what's
what's missing out of four plays in
motion and passion
that really brings in the heat because
see the way the body works the way
hormones work
the way your subhanal the way allah
created is to react
to intimacy is just amazing
it's like you know it's like something
that gets prepared and reaches
a certain like this is when you are
ready or warm
you know like when you're about to do
exercise if you don't stretch or warm up
you can get injured
i mean it's kind of like the same
concept in intimacy if you don't really
warm up it's not going to be the best
subhanallah the body reacts to that so
for example
for a man the
uh sign and of course it's much faster
than the woman
to be ready for intimacy is that he is
erect
all right for a woman the sign that
she's ready for intimacy is that she is
moist or wet all right this is super
just
natural response of the body
all right the man is stimulated visually
as well as
touching but the woman is stimulated by
kissing
touching a lot more things and as the
process
said words okay words and what are words
is literally like
i mean i think the west calls it like
you know dirty talk but you know we need
to
you know be careful with that right but
it's like talking right so the woman
likes to hear you
describing her as beautiful attractive
even to describe a woman's body parts to
her it really turns her on
because a woman likes to feel beautiful
that's one of the things that stops
women from being
properly intimate and enjoying intimacy
[Laughter]
you know i'm laughing you know i'm
laughing i just i just can't stop
look every time i look at ramy bro this
guy just looks like he's just gonna lose
it bro
so i lost it first
[Laughter]
i've been laughing since moist man okay
gabriel probably doesn't know where
that's from you
yeah i'm sorry man oh we i
and i use the term voice and uh it was
just really funny in the context
i mean that's what it is
i don't think so okay all right so i
mean we were
using a very modest words to describe
how to get a woman prepared
right yeah and this man could have said
anything bro he could have said you know
what
he could have said ready warmed up you
know
receptive and this guy just wondering
what moist
oh yeah great minds think alike yeah i
mean i use this here we go
that's why he's the king of intimacy
guys yeah
rami is the king of intimus
hashtag fifty shades of halal
fifty shades yeah
so i mean yeah it is called moisture or
you know
um there's other lubricant
lubricated and that's yeah so that's
that's the reality subhanallah
so once that happens then i guess europe
and subhanallah that's one of the
reasons why i was reading yesterday
through some uh complaints
where women were complaining and it is i
mean again i'm not shy about it because
it is
something that reaches the scholars and
reaches the
counselors but do women do complain that
they're not able to orgasm
very well i don't know 21st century is a
problem when it comes to intimacy of
women complaining about the inability to
reach orgasm
and one of the reason is i believe is is
that the methodology of of
going towards intimacy is because
there's no build up so in an orgasm you
have to reach
a threshold and if there's no build up
and the buildup is
exactly what the prophet saws said is
the words and the kisses it's the
foreplay
right so if you kiss a woman you kiss
her neck you kiss her body you kiss you
know
different uh parts and the woman has a
lot of
um erotic parts on her body that really
stimulate her
and again if people don't understand
that they're not going to be able to use
that
and it's just going to be like okay it's
like two ice cubes you know
get being put together you know that's
nothing's gonna work it's just gonna be
more
cold but you have to reach
through foreplay that
threshold and that's where you basically
close to orgasm
and that's where you're ready for
intercourse actually by
right if the fourth place is correct a
woman only needs about
three to five minutes to climax to
orgasm
but if not if the man just rushes then
there's reports that they need 12 to 18
minutes sometimes more a man can
climax just from uh just from
intercourse within
five minutes sometimes three minutes and
some 30 seconds
30 seconds or even off bro yes and that
is
what's called what's called uh what's
called uh premature ejaculation
all right so this is again the
biologically we're just different
i wouldn't say women are more superior
when it comes to intimacy but i think
they're just more complex and they have
an advantage biologically
number one the points of of turn on are
much more for a woman
and number two they can go longer and
they have
a a a a threshold that they oscillate
within so they can be multi-orgasmic so
they do
if the man pays attention that they can
enjoy sex a lot more
and i do always say in my lectures that
once intimacy is really good
i believe the marriage is really good
the respect of the woman towards the men
is much much better
to sum it up a lot of the marriage
problems is because the man cannot
please the woman
and when i deal with clients where the
man can please the woman
where is there's a lot different respect
the way she looks at him
just when you put two of them together
just the way she reacts to him
the way she looks at him the way she
respects him or talks to him i can say
hey man you know
i think this guy know he knows what he's
doing right so that's
i know it's not all about that i'm not
saying that but today we're talking
about this topic
because i know some people get very
sensitive like you guys all that's all
you talk about oh my god this is so
shameful and i'm like
no because i'm giving you the evidence i
think you need to get out of your
corner out of your hole and just come up
step into the light because these are
the things that are important
and can be talked about and educated
about right so let's not be holier than
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
syndrome you know i mean some people
think they're just better than the
prophet and sahaba
and it causes problems but yeah going
back to the
to the to the to the foreplay
so kissing touching all these are
are for play and they're good they're go
so what's what's permissible
uh anything is permissible uh in this
matter so kissing as we said
words so talking to the woman uh
whispering into her ear
saying she's beautiful taking it easy
don't pushing especially if she's a
virgin if it's your first time there's
you have to understand this woman has
never seen you naked and you've never
seen her naked
uh you haven't been close to each other
there's still an issue of getting to
know each other right how do you know
how do you feel when a stranger comes
and sits next to you that you've never
really
had full interaction with it's kind of
like bro give me some distance right
it's just natural you need to have some
time
to ease in now you've already discussed
and got married so you know
mentally you know okay this is my
husband this my wife but still
from a physiological psychological point
of view
you're still not yet there and that's
the point of intimacy to break that
barrier
and to basically unite the two
so you have to take it easy you have to
understand the woman you have to do the
work
you have to get her into the you know
the heat
the correct temperature through the
kisses
through the stimulation genital
stimulation okay
fingering this all these things are
important talking
that's why the process said words words
can be okay you talk to her
but it's also that you communicate such
as does this feel good
do you like this you know talking
different things
uh maybe not to stimulate um
you know you're beautiful you're this
wow look at that you know touch me here
let's do that talking kissing all these
things and
relaxing it's very important you're like
are you
feeling good now okay uh did you did you
come uh that i have a quick question uh
just to answer says i know angel is
definitely wondering this too
when you say nothing's off the table
that includes dirty talk or what
yeah dirty talk is okay uh some scholars
have said you have to be careful with
what you say
others have said okay as long as it's
not like something really you know
bad and whatnot you know but what is bad
i think i'm talking like degrading dirty
talk because women like that okay
okay i'm not gonna give the uh uh here i
think just listen
to us yeah no fatwas okay uh
but i'm gonna talk from a psychological
perspective here okay
let's let's uh just talk about it yes
some women depends you have to
understand it depends
where you're coming from if it's a
sister coming from
the villages of pakistan or
bangladesh sorry i'm going to be very
but i'm telling you this is not a this
is not a stereotype
i deal with these things right so the
woman will
complain that my husband called me a
bee you know and i was like what the
heck you know did you just say
and that just breaks off the whole night
you know
because in her mind or cult you have
insulted me right now so the guy grew up
in
uk he's a let's say a bangladeshi
brother who grew up on the streets of
london
okay and maybe dated and whatnot and
a different culture and he marries and a
lot of times happens
you know the mother you know beta my son
like i have this sister you know she's
in you know the villages outskirts of
dhaka
and you know we're bringing her here to
london right okay mom she's beautiful
and they're put into the marriage at
night and he says my bee
you know okay or my s
or something right uses a a word right
and she says what you say
you know like i'm gonna tell your mom
you know or something like that and she
gets
turned off and that's it it's not
working okay
however
however there are some sisters
some women and this is again from a
psychological perspective and
based on a lot of simple population
clients
where the woman would be like uh excuse
me like
you need to use some words here because
i'm not feeling it
you know and she was sick call me this
and call me that
uh okay is that good this that
i mean she's been exposed to a different
culture a different thing
yes in some women there is this fetish
to be
called a certain name or to be talked to
a bit more dirty and that really gets
them going
and i want people to not judge here i
want them to just understand where
they're coming from
they've been conditioned in a culture
exposed to a certain thing
and it's changed them and subhanallah a
lot of women cannot climax
unless you use such words okay
unless you become a bit you know vulgar
or dirty and i'm not saying i'm not
giving fatwa
i'm not saying it's permissible or not
i'm just trying to explain
okay what and why okay please don't come
out
now taking things out of context on this
video that
you know brother gibril and the three
muslims are you know saying that this is
you know
uh halal or this is what we should do
i'm just explaining to what
can happen and what happens all right so
yes some words are going to be used and
some behavior as well
as i said some people are asking about
what about rough intercourse or rough
you know uh intimacy and we're gonna
talk about that
because there was a problem you have to
understand how the mind works
like i was reading an article about
fantasies okay
so many women report having a rape
fantasies okay when it comes to intimacy
okay about 62 of the women they were
interviewed reported
having rape fantasies why rape is a bad
thing isn't it
like who wants to be raped and it's such
a huge thing in our society
there's protests and the feminists are
always talking about it men are always
blamed for it
yet women are reporting that i've talked
about this in a video called the
psychology behind sin
there's something stimulating for benny
adam the sons and daughters of adam when
things are not permissible
as i think it's linked to the hadith the
process where
jibreel or angel gabriel he saw jahannam
or hell and he said that it's surrounded
by desires
and he said everyone will be pulled
towards it desires
are linked to impermissible things a lot
of times
not always but a lot of times so i think
people get
stimulated becomes harder when things
are like
a bit dirty or bad and subhanallah a lot
of newlywed
report to me that before
they got married it was all hot you know
they're maybe doing like
not correct haram they're talking
flirting and it was so like exciting or
even
some who had zina and had impermissible
relation
they said man intimacy was so good
as soon as we got married it's like it's
down
you know it's not so good anymore and
what not subhanallah
and i believe it's it's it's due to that
you know it's like people get more
excited when there's
something more stimulating so can we say
necessarily okay we can cut off
everything and you cannot talk a bit
dirty or a bit stimulating to your wife
if you can keep it within the boundaries
i think this is we're going to leave it
to the people themselves to decide but
they have to have
some boundaries and you have to be
careful because sometimes you
you keep going go and go on go you're
never going to be satisfied you're just
going to go
down a slippery slope right but is
very intimacy sorry foreplay is
critical for intimacy and if on the
marriage night you don't do that
you don't ease into it you don't feel
make your
wife feel comfortable and you rush
things a few things can happen number
one
trauma because if you push on to her
you can traumatize her or you can be
traumatized
if you rush yourself you can have a lot
of men have
um premature ejaculation as you said bro
i feel you know before even the pants
are off the guy has already
ejaculated and literally the woman says
you're done that's it you know and it
does become traumatic because the guy
he feels a shame so for example one of
my clients the
the woman the next day went to her to
his mom
and says you know your your son didn't
do anything last night
and it became a huge family problem the
guy was so ashamed you know it's like so
disrespectful
in other cases the guy you know doesn't
want to talk about it turns around
goes to sleep another case i had last
week was literally like
you know they're in bed and the guy just
fell asleep he didn't do anything
you know what i mean i mean it's just
it's it's embarrassing because why
people don't know how to or they don't
understand or they think it's wrong or
they just don't have any guidance people
don't really talk about this
issue so it's trauma for the guy he's
gonna be embarrassed he's to have
premature
he's not going to be able to enjoy he
doesn't feel like a man
and subhanallah if the knight of
marriage is not
guided and sorry but like ruled and
dominated by the man
forget about it man the wife will not
respect you
in general and even i could say that's
like a precursor for
who's gonna wear the pants in the family
because if the woman knows you're weak
in that
field and she controls it she's got
superiority of course she doesn't have
to be erect she's just a receiver
then you're in for troubleman okay
you're in for trouble
so the guy has to take it easy how can
he traumatize her well if he's been
taught and he's been um
educated by pornography then he might
just unleash the beast on her
and he will traumatize her if she's not
ready if she's ready maybe you know
she's
also like had some history
this we we're talking about real things
here you know
because the muslims sometimes they think
okay just theoretical virgin virgin
never saw porn never saw porn village
village come together
okay everything will work out perfectly
it's not like that
all right it's not like that so he can
traumatize her
he can do things to her that he thinks
is the right way to do it because he saw
it in a video or something like that
and subhanallah even some of my clients
they reported that sometimes
the man asks look at this to watch porn
with his wife
on the marriage night so one sister
wrote like i don't know what to do it's
before the marriage the deca has not
been done
are you saying like what should i do my
husband is asking he's already preparing
that we're gonna watch
porn together while we're having
intimacy and i was like subhanallah
what kind of thinking is that you know
like where's your
your like you're gonna expose your wife
to see another man
doing another woman what is this you
know but this is the kind of
mentality that people bring into the
marriage night
and it causes trauma when trauma happens
and it's associated with that beautiful
uh you know the beautiful night
the beautiful act of being intimate or
making love
then of course throughout your life
there's gonna be
problems because something that was
supposed to be beautiful becomes ugly
something that's supposed to unite and
bond your marriage becomes something
disgusting
the woman starts man starts saying oh i
don't know my wife doesn't want to sleep
with me
then when you talk to the woman yeah but
you know five years ago when we got
married he
you know did this to me and did that to
me and since then i lost respect i can't
even
look at him blah blah blah and then it
ends up in
a mess so again for those who ask why
you guys talking about this this
is why we are talking about
this so yes
definitely definitely having
intimacy or having the pre-intimacy
the warm-up the uh you know the foreplay
is extremely
important to build uh as i said
stimulation kissing touching being naked
subhanallah some muslims believe that
you cannot look at your wife's naked
body
i had a discussion with brown brother
who said that you have to wear uh
something or you have to turn off the
lights or put a sheet in between you
this is more
this is a weak opinion and no nothing
the processor used to take bath with
same place in the same tub okay
there's no such thing of course looking
at your wife's
i mean imagine subhanallah you're on the
street every day and we should
lower our gaze but come on let's be
honest man you lower your gaze you're
going to see something even just the
first look as the processor said the
first look is forget forgiven
you're going to see some skin man 21st
century
i don't know you live in miami or where
uh at the moment clairemont it's florida
so bad for you man
you started that man you still seen
spring break yes
listen brother i was telling romney and
fire the other day i went to the mall
with my family
and i went into this
and store the cashier lady had this
white shirt on
no bra and she had this strap going
across
where like you you could literally see
her and i wanted to go and be like
sister you might as well not have worn a
shirt i could see everything
no so imagine imagine you're exposed to
that even here in malaysia bro if i want
to go out for lunch more just from my
office
it's like skin bro you know just skin
everywhere
so imagine you're telling a man after
coming home
from 10 12 hours or whatever being
exposed to these things
and then the woman or the you know
instead you cannot look at your wife's
uh body you know what i mean
come on man like that's just ridiculous
that's your
escape that's your halal right so these
are allowed to look at each other to
play with each other to touch each other
uh stimulation of the genitalia okay
what's called [ __ ] fingering whatever
in street terms right and of course it
leads us to the topic of oral sex
i don't know how much time we have but i
just wanted to slip something in
real quick no homo we have uh we have
seven minutes left before i gotta go
break my fast
i think this episode we can just wrap it
up with
foreplay right next episode can be more
on
i mean at this rate bro we're never
going to actually get to the intimacy
the next episode we're going to talk
about the orgasm nah i'm just joking
uh yeah so we can we we have the orgasm
you know technique all that is going to
come up
but if there's any final thoughts for
foreplay we can just get it out there
i know i know rami has a lot to say
i have two things but romney go ahead
romney go ahead bro you've been you've
been awfully selling for a while
allah um i don't actually have anything
to say about foreign
the most important thing it's
brother gabriel said masha allah um
honestly
uh i don't know if it's if it's laziness
from a guy if it's not ignorance it must
be laziness
um it's not gonna work i want to say
trust me but i mean
i'm not actually the king of missy so i
can't say that but
um yeah foreplay it and it's very simple
it's very simple like you could just
whisper a few words
give her something sweet to eat touch
her a little bit tell her to tell her to
like spin around or something
um you know play around a little bit and
uh just make her feel good
just have a good time and all that
and uh what the brother was about to
talk about um
uh you know oral sex and um
uh you know hand jobs and fingering and
all that stuff using your hands as well
um if you can get a woman uh really
heavily stimulated
um or even orgasming before you've even
started the actual intimacy then
you're golden you're good uh so that's
that's my uh
two cents fellas we don't call him the
king of intimacy for no reason come on
now
i just wanted to say something real
quick before hannah goes in um think
about it anatomically like
we are literally like if you if you
think about the penis versus the vagina
it literally propagates forward like
this the way we were designed
is to lead but with that being said yes
the girl is kind of like a flower like
he needs to like blossom you can't
go in if it's not ready for you you get
what i mean there's
it's not it's not receptive so to make
it easy
you have to have foreplay i would even
say foreplay
is more important for the female orgasm
than actual intimacy
can that's a very good point go for it
bro
uh i want to add two things from my
jahilia days
all right number one is uh first off
subhanallah
the prophet this man he knew everything
uh because from my jahilia i can report
that you can indeed
get a woman to uh i'ma use the term get
off
obviously you guys can understand that
as an orgasm
but you can make a woman get off
before you even
penetrate before you do anything it's
all about like the way
you speak the way you interact with her
the way you carry yourself
and all these little things that like
does it for her
before you guys even get to the point
where you are like that and
some of it is not even sexual some of it
is not even sexual but it still affects
the woman in the sexual way
subhanallah and the second thing that i
can report from my jahilia is uh
gabriel you said that women are
multi-orgasmic
right and most would say that men are
not
multi-orgasm because we we ejaculate one
time
and then we have a refractory period we
have a period where it's like we have to
kind of recover
and then we can go back into it but
there's this thing
known as a dry orgasm which actually
allows the man to
be multi-orgasm yes
which talk we could definitely talk
about that in the
the next video very good very good
just fyi guys orgasm is not ejaculation
it is an orgasm right you don't have to
ejaculate to have an orgasm as a man
you think you do but you know all right
that's a very good point you can't
adjust accurate without having an orgasm
but you can't have an orgasm without a
jacket without ejaculation yes
all right yeah all right
hashtag king rami anything else
[Laughter]
hashtag
so i guess we leave the the other stuff
especially the
the topic of oral sex before i mean for
for next episode inshallah it's a very
important topic
and but just to recap right so
towards the marriage night during the
marriage night a man
is the leader i think uh vader said it
very well the way allah designed this
subhanallah just
dude understand how much sperm we
produce
man and how much that sperm works it's a
powerhouse
we are a powerhouse man a woman produces
uh or releases about one egg per month
one
a man releases millions of sperms
so even the the anatomy is like as you
said we're leading forward the woman
receives she's supporting
it's like if you have um
a sword right and you put the
the sword into the the protection right
it's like it's supposed to right so the
sign like the
the male goes inside the woman it's
there's a protection there there's a
a backup a cover right the woman always
is of support right but the man is the
one who cuts he's the leader he's the
one who pushes
subhanallah you know this this just the
anatomy of that
refutes feminist ideology and you know
sadly the sisters who are falling for
this
ideology but yeah the man is the leader
he needs to take it so he's got to pace
himself
okay for his own benefit and for the
benefit of his wife inshallah
uh he has to use all kinds of techniques
as per the process
talking kissing stimulating and so on
and as arami rightly said
like you if you and you should like i
have this
theory it's like there's a ratio of
two to one is like the bottom like that
should be your least
but it should be it should bear me but
it should be three to one so what's that
three to one means means she has three
or two orgasms before you have one
okay that should be like you're giving
you should never be one to one
men should never if you are provided one
yeah that's another issue we're going to
talk about females not having orgasm at
all and it's a
big problem bro and they fake it because
they don't want to
hurt the guy and uh the guy thinks he's
you know he's good and what not
it's big big problems but it should be
two to one or three to one
and indeed at least one or two should be
before penetrating as rami said right
because then
it also removes the pressure from the
guy and it
stops him from having this premature and
it kind of removes the pressure
of what's called performance anxiety
which can make a man go
down okay which is yeah it is in the
mind so once you've scored once twice
then you're men
okay and your woman is going to let you
know that this is you know a guy's
asked sometimes how do i know if my girl
has an orgasm
you will know me you you will know bro
she will tell you or you should not tell
your body will tell you we can get into
that in some of the signs okay and how
you can make the
distinction between a fake one and a
real one
okay because and we'll talk about the
psychology behind that right
so yes i believe that can lead will lead
us inshallah to actual
yeah so we'll talk about oral sex and
then intercourse inshallah and some
techniques and
yeah inshallah inshallah this video
we're going to talk about
maintenance as well yeah this video has
been
literally foreplay for the viewers
it was like look at how gabriel left it
off
he was just about to go into uh handy's
blowies and i i know i use like the most
nastiest terms i'm sorry if i'm so
enjoying i've heard
yes i have too i'm trying to be very
generous here
and modest but um
look look look gabriel is leaving on
such a high note he's leaving everybody
high and dry
just like just pretty much he's
he's leaving everybody moist
shall they go to their wives inshallah
and uh women can go to the shop
as for the ones who are not married as
we gave the disclaimer before don't
watch this if you're not
you know because we don't want you guys
don't don't dislike this video just
because you have some
projection or cognitive bias against you
know
pleasing your woman or anything like
that just remember you disliking this
video you trying to
you know spread heat less people are
gonna have
proper intimacy the oma will you know
lack proliferation
and then come on you know don't you want
to be a part like this video comment the
video help the algorithm
do you not want to be a part of you know
sharing these blessings sharing these
barakah
helping more people you know that like
bro every time somebody
does intimacy properly because of this
video first and foremost it's from allah
but
this video is the buttercup like we're
gonna get the blessing so why not be a
part of this
yes very well
guys yes bro i think this was a lot of
foreplay
i think i think they're ready for next
episode
once it comes out stay tuned in the
meantime comment down below
any specific questions you have once
again we will not go too much
into fatwas um it'll just be anecdotal
experience um
you know we're not gonna say anything
haram for sure um insha allah
but if you guys have any questions like
brother gabriel said we will talk a
little bit about oral sex
uh a little more about other things to
get off and as angel said
then we're gonna go more into intimacy
after that inshallah talk about how to
maintain that maintain your marriage
stuff like that frequency of the orgasm
frequency of how many times you should
be doing it per week or per month
um menstruation during ramadan inshallah
for sure
all right guys mommy ended up bro
anybody uh
if anyone dislikes this video their sex
life
must suck you don't agree with us on any
of this and like
i wish you the best male 1 put him on
the spot
y'all heard
[Music]
speak about positions too right yes of
course
there's some ideas about that as well
positions locations
the different like rhythms yeah like the
stroke patterns sure can uh as i said
stefano
one of the sisters sent the message and
then a lot of people commented should i
try to post these
questions without this uh without the
name
just to see what's the reaction to
people and they're asking about the
whole
50 shades of grey that you know the book
and the movie
because i have a history about that as
well what happened in our community at
that time when the book came out
how the sisters reacted it was a huge
problem man it was big
big marital issues you know that that
book caused
because the women were going crazy over
that book the muslim women
so we'll discuss that yeah
stuck so wrong man all right
inshallah sounds good if there are no
more suggestions then
this is your q viewers if you guys have
suggestions comment down below
and also comment down your any questions
and any opinions any thoughts you may
have
if you're looking to support us and
check out our patreon insha allah
with the lowest tier being five dollars
and
with that being said for watching
brother gabriel for joining us again for
another episode
oh hold up as far as possible i just
remember what i was gonna say
yeah gabriel we definitely need to talk
about that because there's a lot of
people or i should say there's a lot of
guys out there
who they don't know how to make love
and i'll be honest i don't think i know
how to make love you know i think
every single guy has like this nate uh
feeling of like
jackhammering and a girl sometimes will
say like oh i want to make
love and we're just like oh okay so
let me let me put the speed setting on
slow
we're going to just
yeah because i feel like women prefer
different things based on different
times of the month
yep it's a good one that's a really good
one so make sure angel
that's yeah let's make sure the second
king of
the prince of intimacy
all right guys okay remember comment
like really helps the algorithm because
you know youtube doesn't like real
content like this right so this is what
it is but
we have the army so we're ready all
right
i love that being said
foreign
a lot of people have this misconception
that you know once i feel closer to god
then i'm going to start practicing
it's backwards you won't feel close to
god until you start practicing the
prophet i said
there's a hadith where he says that the
most beloved acts of worship to god are
those which he made obligatory the
person continues to get closer and
closer to allah
key point gets closer and closer by
voluntary acts of good so like sudden
things you know for the sake of allah
things that are not obligatory but you
do them just to please allah
until allah begins to love the person so
two things you want to feel close to
allah you want allah to love you
do what allah prescribes for you which
is
so praying fasting
and then on top of that sunnah prayers
sudden fasts
giving extra charity to the point where
allah will insha allah begin to love you
[Music]
[Music]
hmm